good morning John I like the idea of all
things more than I like the actual way
that they're done like I like the idea
of a national anthem I just don't like
our national anthem bombs explosions in
war that was America's about it about
explosions and war and there are some
things about America that I like more
than explosions in war or to take
another example the Happy Birthday song
I love that there's a Happy Birthday
song that we all know the words to and
that is part of our cultural memory but
I don't like the Happy Birthday song
because the Happy Birthday song is a bad
song happy birthday to go my god just
get it over what so we can get to the
game because the cake is the part that I
really like that's how I feel about a
lot of holidays including Thanksgiving I
really like the idea of a day in which
we just say what we're thankful for but
then you have to go and mix it up with
gorging yourself on 4,000 calories of
deep-fried turkey flesh and beer and I
get very confused about what exactly
we're trying to be thankful for here are
we are we thankful for gluttony cuz I'm
not really feeling that so instead this
Thanksgiving and true hankering style I
am going to give you 50 things that I am
thankful for I am thankful for open
source software my new phone which runs
on open source software YouTube
obviously really good design thoughtful
urban planning anyone who is willing to
risk their lives to save other people
and whatever way that you're doing that
chickens both dead and alive just the
idea of Wolverine she the first
generation of youtubers you all know who
you are
medicine peace young adult literature
video games in which the main characters
are abnormally adorable a little bit
ashamed of that one but it's okay
video games in which I get to kill
people with guns I'm even more ashamed
of that Wow ah
zombies but only zombies that dance so
if you're not dancing zombies I'm not
thankful for you being my age and still
thinking that farts are funny and also
having a wife who is my age and also
thinks that farts are funny
investigative journalism Moore's Law
Carl Sagan auto-tuning auto-tuning Carl
Sagan xkcd consumers producing instead
of consuming hot showers solar power
libraries teachers everyone who buys one
of my this machine poems noobs shirts
people who don't think that me selling
things that I've created through my
creative endeavors is selling out I'm
not selling pharmaceuticals or handbags
or soda pop here people I'm selling the
stuff that I'm proud of GPS also GPS
very thankful for that
especially after my tour evolutionary
theory Thank You Darwin and all the many
people who have continued developing
evolutionary theory linear time travel
into the future which is what we're all
doing
I think it'd be really confusing
otherwise friends all my friends
giraffes
especially giraffes who are mating my
bed stars the application on my phone
that lets me finally know what the names
of all the constellations are every one
of my cat I'm thankful for my cat
independent comic book companies the
idea of wrapping carbohydrates around
any kind of flavored protein whether
that's a peanut butter sandwich a
calzone a meat pie or whatever
low-priced and high-quality consumer
electronics the fact that there is clean
cool drinkable water that pours out of
all these holes inside of my house
whenever I want it I'm thankful for that
bottle John my guitar nerdfighters and
nerdfighteria thank you so much Oh J
Frank my wife and that's all I want to
do this Thanksgiving okay I also want to
eat some food and watch some football
I'll be honest but other than that I
just want the world to know how thankful
I am for this marvelous life that we all
get to live dftba
[Music]
you